tonight Gridiron Playoff hopefuls will
ask our judges are you buying in first
up the 2022 Saints hey so you should buy
it I'm sorry pal it's a no for us oh
coach Payton if you're watching this
take me wherever
next up his dad founded FedEx but will
his playoff invite get lost in the mail
Pitt's production is way down yards down
catches down we're out looking for a
partial buy-in on a wild card valuation
Odell spin around for me now dance dance
roll down you know a good sauce can
cover up a bad taste mmm spicy I guess
I'm like half inch there's a second New
York team hit it everyone's laughing
with me right uh they do have really
good numbers thank you but I'm declining
the offer we just said you'll win the
AFC South no one deserves to win that
division we're in the top percent of the
fourth quarter plus we just named our
new coach the 2014 AFC finalist Banner a
proven winner Mr say it did beat the
Raiders coming up next Who Wants To Be A
Commander's owner all right all right
seems like this is the easiest way to
get a new team
[Music]
yeah beg beg for me Jerry Jones okay
hold on wait how many fashion weeks does
buffalo have none rename Jerry world oh
Dell world do it old man